[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Hello.
I'm going to welcome Sarah.
Sarah Gold is an expert in
data management and privacy.
She sits on the board
of Tech for Good.
And she is going to talk
to us about the trust
and digital rights
in learning systems.
SARAH GOLD: Thank you.
At IF we believe that services
should respect our rights.
So we work with
the organizations
shaping our digital
world to show how
they can be trusted with data.
Over the last couple
of years, we've
worked with a whole range
of different organizations.
And our work is
increasingly taking us
to quite a specific part
of machine intelligence,
looking specifically at how
people can trust services that
are powered by machine
intelligence technologies
but also how machine
intelligence technologies can
be trustworthy in
the first place.
This is a really
important area of work
because services
are increasingly
being powered by machine
intelligence technologies.
And those services
are beginning to creep
into really important
areas of our life,
whether that be helping
you to find a job
or to manage your finances
or, as we found out last week,
deciding on who to vote for.
At this point, I
want to re-frame
what I mean by machine
intelligence technologies.
Matt Jones uses the
phrase learned systems.
And I think it's
really effective
because I think it helps us
to refocus the issue on people
and society, which are the
most important things, really.
It also reminds us that we
actively teach these systems.
And they operate in
a real world context
that we must never forget about.
So I'm going to talk to
you about two things, trust
and rights in learned systems.
To start, I'm going
to talk about trust.
And I'm going to give you
an overview of six insights
that we have found from our
work at IF working directly
on these issues.
And whilst I can't show you
exact examples, because I'd
be in breach of
confidentiality agreements,
I have found examples to
illustrate these points
from the public domain
or illustrations
from IF's blog to show you.
So to start off, design
for non-determinism.
As designers, we are
used to designing
for fixed circumstances.
It's kind of like
if this, then that.
With learned systems,
that completely changes.
As designers, we
don't necessarily
know what a user will see once
the system is showing them
a service because there's
an infinite number
of possible interfaces
that a user might be shown.
As a user, that creates a
real challenge for trust.
Because how can you start
to have conversations
with one another to check
is my thing working right,
does this look good
to you, is this
what it should be showing me,
if everyone's service is showing
them something different.
That's a real challenge.
At IF, we think that
designers should
start thinking about
designing for frameworks
for learned systems to express
a range of opportunities within.
That's why as of today,
we've launched a project
with Alison Powell from the
London School of Economics
looking at just that.
What do these
frameworks look like?
And how do you
design transparency
into the frameworks
so that users
are able to understand
and challenge
what a learned system
presents them with?
If you'd like to
follow that project,
please do take a photograph of
that blog post linked there.
We'll be working on it
over the next few months.
Design for legibility
and understanding
is another principle.
Just like handwriting,
if someone's handwriting
is really messy, it's
really difficult for you
to read what they've written.
In the same way, I
think that services are
really hard for users to read.
And not only that, they're
super difficult to understand
even if you can read them.
I'd like to ask the audience how
many of use Spotify or iTunes
or Google Play?
Hands up.
And keep your hands up if
you've read the terms of service
updates recently.
No one kept their hand up.
That's right.
We know that terms of service
or terms and conditions
are not good enough for
the digital services
that we use today, let
alone learned systems.
At IF, we think it's possible
to begin designing terms
of service out by putting the
information about when services
are learning, what data is being
used, and what powers a user
has to change that, all
at the point of use.
You can see on the
example to the left,
this is an example of a
fictional benefits service
that we prototyped at IF.
And you can see that this
individual has received
a sanction on their benefit.
What we were interested
in doing here
is showing why the individual
received that sanction,
to give them that information
at the point of use
and give them an option to
appeal that decision if they
think that something's
not quite right.
This is all about the
service explaining itself
as it's being used.
And we think this
is something that
will be really important as we
see more and more services are
powered by learned systems.
In the meantime, before we
ditch the terms of service,
we think it's possible
to make terms of service
more legible and
easier to understand.
We've blogged about
some of our thinking
on that at understanding
terms and conditions.
And I'd encourage you to look
there at some of the techniques
that we think are important
to make terms of service
more machine readable and more
understandable to you and I.
Design for override is
another interesting area.
This is because trust is
a two-way relationship.
So it really wouldn't be any
good if a learned system simply
presented a user with
decisions that it
had made without the user
being able to give feedback
or to take over.
I think it's really
important that users
are given the ability to
take over critical automated
processes.
And that means that the
user has to know they can
take over and understand how.
This is important for
a host of reasons.
One of them is skills fade.
There's a really nice parallel
in the transport for London.
Every Sunday the
London Underground
turn off automatic braking to
make sure that drivers of tubes
don't lose their skills from
the automated safety system.
I think that's a
really nice parallel.
And I think there are things
we should draw from that
in our work on services.
Design for recovery is another.
So systems are
going to go wrong.
That will happen.
And it's really
important for the user
to be able to remove any
autonomy that the system has
or to revert back to a previous
system that didn't fail.
And that should be
possible without having
systemic failure.
This is a bit like
cruise control in a car.
You can have cruise
control on for a long time
and enjoy the car kind
of driving you somewhere.
But as soon as you see
something quite unusual up ahead
or a difficult junction, you
should be able to take over.
That's really important
because there are some actions
that you'll be able to navigate
better than any system.
Design for
respectability, this is
all about making
sure that a user can
see what a learned
system is doing and why.
It's a bit like view source
on the web that we have now.
Or, apologies for
another car analogy,
but if you've ever checked
the oil in your engine,
it's like that.
You should have the ability
to check what's happening.
And then there's design
for collective action.
So whilst more technology
and more design
is needed in this area,
they're not the only answers.
And in fact, the answer
isn't just about more design,
more technology, because we
have to think about the wider
system.
And it's really
important that we
think about the needs of
different levels of society.
We really can't fall into
the trap of this Californian
ideology that to
understand a learned system
or to trust it will be purely
an individualistic action.
I think it's really
important to think
about collective action, by
which I mean things we can only
do together or with the
help of organizations
that can represent us.
At IF, we've been looking at
how consumer groups, unions
or medical charities
can help people
they represent understand if a
learned system can be trusted.
But also those organizations can
help society as a whole course
correct.
You can see the
example on the left,
going back to that
fictional benefits
service I showed earlier, that
the individual that received
that sanction was
quite concerned
that that sanction was wrong.
So they went to an organization
called Citizens Advice.
Citizens Advice is an
organization in the UK
that helps citizens navigate
complexity and hard situations
in government services.
So this individual who
has received the sanction
goes to Citizens Advice.
And the advisor
at Citizens Advice
is able to see why
that section was given
and if anyone else in that area
was given a similar sanction
for the same reason.
What's important
here, as you can
see the kind of
highlighted decision
at the top, this
question, which is
that 153 other people
in the Salford area
have missed
appointments in April.
Would you like to
include Mary's case?
Because maybe it's that the
bus timetable has changed
in Salford, so no
one in that area
can make the right
appointment time.
So letting organizations
help us means we can also
have collective action.
So we can course correct
so we can see as a society
where these systems
might go wrong
and, hopefully, early
enough before they
cause huge problems.
Of course, that
means that you're
designing a learned
system, you really
need to think about where your
learned system fits in society
and with civic institutions.
If you'd like to look at more
about what we've been thinking
about at IF on that, we
wrote a blog post last year
on making it clear how
machines make decisions.
This leads onto the
next part of my talk
which is all about rights.
So I think that these are
three areas that I would argue
urgently need addressing by us.
The first is GDPR
learned systems.
GDPR is the General Data
Protection Regulation.
It comes into force
in May this year.
It affects every company
that holds any information
about any EU citizen.
Essentially, for
us as individuals,
it gives us a whole
suite of digital rights.
Some of them are
really interesting.
And if you'd like to see
what those rights could mean
for services that you
might use every day,
we did some sketching
a couple of years ago.
And you can find those
under newdigitalrights
.projectsbyIF.com.
GDPR's rights directly
challenge some
of the ways that learned
systems are built.
And that's where these
challenges and the questions
I have for you come in.
So what is an individual's
right to deletion
in a federated learning model?
Because people are complex,
data that they give a service
could be wrong.
Or the data they
give a service could
be right at one moment
in time and wrong now.
For instance, if someone
has a divorce, that
will have an impact on maybe
how they use their bank account,
perhaps the kind of invitations
they make in their calendar,
or simply what
images it would not
be OK to show them in
their social media feed.
These are kind of everyday
problems that everyone has
and these systems need
to be able to respond to.
So it needs to be possible for
this kind of ephemeral design
to work where a system can
explain the learning it's
got to a user, and the user can
choose to keep it or throw it
away.
So my question is
how can we make
ephemeral learning possible
in a privacy preserving way?
And how can we make
ephemeral design work?
Another one is how can
you give a user the right
to understand in this world
that's nondeterministic
that I explained earlier?
I think this is a
really tricky question.
And I think we have to
think about the way we deal
with data permissions
and collective action
to answer some of this because
I think data privacy is just
far too complex a thing to be
regulated by individuals who
are really busy doing important
things like making their money
stretch or finding
food at a food bank.
They don't have time to
tweak data permissions,
or let alone the skills, to
check that their choices are,
in fact, being respected.
And this is where
I think we have
to think about groups that
can represent many of us
to help us understand whether
certain data should be given
to a service and if that
service is respecting
the choices that we made.
Testing in learned systems
is the second area,
so any system of any
complexity in society
has required testing.
If we take an example of a
fridge, a fridge in your home
will have been tested by
consumer rights organizations
to make sure that that
fridge doesn't set alight
in your home.
The manufacturer
will have also tested
that fridge to make
sure that it keeps
your food at a temperature
that's safe to eat at.
The manufacturer also
will have designed it
to standards that have been
iterated and decided that this
is how we build a fridge.
Now, if you take that
testing ecosystem question,
that will be necessary
in learned systems.
But how can you create a testing
ecosystem that doesn't just
test a kind of inanimate
object like a fridge
that its performance
only changes
with age but a learned system
that can change in minutes?
So how can we create a testing
ecosystem that keeps pace
with the changes of software?
Within this as well, we'll
have different people running
different models on devices.
So how do we verify
the authenticity
of different
versions of models so
that people can make sure
that the model they're using
is trusted?
DeepMind are developing
verifiable data audit,
which is a technology
that essentially
logs all the different
kinds of health information
that DeepMind use to provide
their services that are used
by clinicians to make better
decisions about people's care
or treatment.
Verifiable data
audit is essentially
a log of lots of
information you'd
need to look back
at to understand
how did the clinician make
the decision at the time?
What information was available
to them to make that decision?
Verifiable data audit is
just one kind of technology
that could help us verify
complex learning systems.
But I think there
will be other things
we need too, like, for instance,
open registries, perhaps,
of verified models.
Or maybe we need to start
verifying the training data
that we use in the first place.
So how do we publish
that other data?
How do we verify
the authenticity
of different training models?
And then, what
training is needed
for the individuals
who will be running
those testing institutions
or organizations
in the first place?
And something I'm
really interested in
is how do we give testing
suites to individuals
so they don't just have to
run on our organizations,
but they can self
test things too.
The last area I
want to talk about
is something that's
really close to my heart.
And this is ownership and
control in learned systems
because these systems
don't operate in isolation.
They exist as part
of a wider system.
And we've seen with Facebook
and Cambridge Analytica what
happens if the wrong parts of a
learned system and the platform
it operates on is closed,
obfuscated, illegible,
or has perverse
incentives baked into it.
So when you use a service
that learns from your behavior
and makes decisions
on your behalf,
whether that be about deciding
what brand of loo paper to buy
or maybe which school
to send your child to,
how can you know
that that system is
working in your best interests?
Then as those decisions are
made, not just about you
but maybe about
your community, how
can you know that that system
understands right from wrong?
What is right, anyway?
As humans, we have morality.
But when we're talking
about, essentially, what
is a bunch of numbers, how
do we make sure that that can
understand or know what's best?
When you use a doctor or
an engineer or a lawyer,
they have a professional code of
ethics that they must work to.
So how can we make the
intent of a learned system
clear to a user?
And where do you think a
system's ethical premise should
be logged?
The other question
I have is which
parts of a learned system and
the platform it operates on
can be of the market?
Which parts of the learned
system and the platform
it operates on has to be open,
co-operative, commonly owned,
and not part of the market?
That's really important
because if there's not
enough transparency baked into
the way we design and build
these systems, how can
society ever course correct?
You'll remember the
financial crisis.
That was a systems
failure of huge proportion
that affected everyone
around the world.
But it most affected
those individuals
who have least most severely.
I think these areas are
the most pertinent issues
to be investigating in design
because what you design
affects the
understanding and access
that an individual
has to their rights
and their ability to
have action on them.
It is our responsibility
to make sure
that we design learned systems
so that they can be trusted
and that they give
people digital rights.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: Questions?
AUDIENCE: I share, probably,
most people's intimidation
of legal terminology
in contracts and stuff.
And it strikes me that
perhaps there are,
as you say, something
that can be parsed or made
simpler to understand.
But at the same time,
a big part of what
I think makes them complex
is that all of that language
is there for specificity.
It's details, basically, right?
And so in a certain
way, it strikes me
that it's kind of
like saying, why
do we need all this code
in this computer program?
Why can't it just do the thing
that it's supposed to do?
I don't know if
that's a fair analogy.
So my question is,
basically, can you
elaborate a little bit on how
to kind of bubble that up?
And I guess the
final point on this
is that it seems like often
the thing that screws a person
with legal language
is not the top level
point but the thing that's
kind of buried deep in there.
SARAH GOLD: So I
think the question
was about the relevance of
terms of service to a designer.
And then the second part
was what are the ways
to design out terms of service?
Is that kind of right?
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
My question was basically
how do you envision
clarifying this kind of
language or this kind of system
to laypeople without losing the
details in those documents that
are sort of crucial to--
SARAH GOLD: OK, I see.
So I think that having terms
of service that sometimes you
can't even find very easily
on a service, I mean,
that just doesn't work at all.
Because even if you wanted to
try and go back to understand
something, you can't.
Or you're not even
sure which version
it was that you saw when you
signed up to the service.
So I think that there are--
it's really important that
an individual understands
what information is being
collected, when a service is
learning, what that data is used
to do, all the details of it,
actually, when it's
relevant to them.
So I think as you go
through a service,
I think there are
points of asking
for consent as a service is
running that is a good idea as
opposed to asking
for all the consent
up front, which is
what currently happens.
So I think getting
smarter about how
we can bring in consent
throughout a service.
But we have to do that
with a lot of research
because I think a
speaker earlier mentioned
about getting in the way.
And that's often
part of the tension
here is you need to add
friction points to help
someone understand.
But at the same time, someone
may just fundamentally not
understand why that could
be relevant to them.
And I think that's
part of the problem,
actually, is that with learned
systems the quantity of data
that is being
extracted is so huge,
I think it's going to be almost
impossible for the majority
of people to understand that.
So I think that looking at how
the issues of terms of service
gets designed across the service
is one way to look at it.
But I think, ultimately,
what we should be looking at
and, Tom Steinberg blogged
about this recently,
is what are the kind of
collection action points
to understand this stuff?
You just want to be
able to use a service,
to receive the utility
it provides you,
and not have to worry.
And the majority of people
just don't have time to check.
So I think we have
to look to that.
But also I think there's a
question about how machines
can also help us check
because of the quantities
of information we're looking at.
AUDIENCE: So to extend this
notion of legal systems
as code or code as legal
systems, as you well know,
regulatory environments and
laws are often in conflict
within a nation.
And so for example, a program
would crash at that point
through a memory error.
But legal systems
keep churning on.
And of course, a lot
of lawyer activity
is applying the
correct regulation
for the correct
circumstance and ignoring
that one that's in conflict.
Now, of course, we are
developing technology
that has to live in an
international environment
where it's not
enough to just have
consistent laws within a
nation, but we, the technology
providers and
builders, have to build
things that are
consistent across
international boundaries.
Copyright, for example, varies
tremendously from country
to country.
Australia regulations are very
different than US and so on.
Tell us what we
should be thinking
about when one country
demands that you delete
this data and another country
demands you maintain that data.
Suggestions?
SARAH GOLD: Well, so this is
an area that I'm really, really
interested in.
And I think that
technology companies--
I mean, there's a question
about your experiences
as you go from
country to country,
or as I've come here,
the fact that there
was at that point in time where
there was a lot of concern
that at an airport
you could be asked
to give over your passwords.
And there was no way of
me going dark on my phone,
so to speak, right?
Maybe that should have been an
affordance that an organization
should have given me.
So this is a question
that I'm not going
to say I have an answer to.
But I think it's something
where we need to be
designing with the legal teams.
I think that when you see
design and development teams,
they're often in completely
different buildings to where
legal are.
And so I think far
more collaboration
between those groups to
understand these issues.
AUDIENCE: Although there
is a bug with that, right?
The legal universe
that I deal with
is way behind the technology
that we're developing.
I don't know how many times I've
had to explain how HTML works
and how a web browser works.
It actually makes a copy
on your local device.
That's a crazy hard notion
for lawyers to understand.
SARAH GOLD: But I
think that's where
we have to look at this as
being a cultural question.
So when you look at
programs like Oxfam's Data
Responsibility Program
that they brought
in with the engine
[INAUDIBLE] that was something
that wasn't about more design.
It was actually about
facilitating workshops
to bring different parts of
the organization together
to discuss really knotty
issues of things like consent
in somewhere like Yemen.
So I think it has to come from
a place of bringing people
together that have not
been together before.
And as designers,
remember, we're
really good at doing that.
You know, we are facilitators.
So I think that
has to come first.
But I'd love to do
more work on that.
And I'd love to talk to
you after about that.
I think it's not a question
I can answer super quick.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
I'm from DeepMind
Ethics and Society.
So I was very
interested in your idea
that certain parts
of the system should
operate outside of the market.
And I was wondering if
you could flesh that out
for us a little bit more?
SARAH GOLD: Yeah, I think this
is one of the big research
questions that, actually,
we need to explore and needs
steady academic research,
as well, so that this
can be in the open
because I think
it's a really important one.
I think that it's all
about incentives, I think.
So if you have all
parts of learned systems
and the platforms
that they operate
on built to a model
of capitalism,
we know what happens
with that model.
And we also know what
happens with parts
of the infrastructure that
are critical to running that,
the open-source infrastructure,
that may not receive
any funding or has
security issues in it
because it's not well resourced.
We're going to see
those issues again
but at a much, much bigger
scale with learned systems.
I think we have to learn
from what we know and think
about which parts of
these systems have to be,
what I would call,
of the commons.
And I hope that Dan Hill, later,
might speak a little bit more
to some of these
issues of ownership.
And that's really important
because when something
is of the commons or
cooperatively owned,
there are rules that you set
as a group of individuals
that you all get to decide on.
So it's really going down
to fundamentals of power
in these systems.
And by power, I mean what kind
of rights and capabilities
these systems give
the majority of us.
And I think that's incredibly
important to look at.
And it's something we
have to see, particularly
at the speed of software change.
And we just won't
be able to keep up.
We really won't.
And I think there is a real risk
that we will see huge systems
failure again and
again and again
if we don't give society
the ability to see ahead
and course correct.
That's only going
to be possible if we
make the important parts of
these platforms and systems
open.
That's what I mean.
AUDIENCE: Mine is more of a
comment to a conversation I'd
like to provoke.
I think I actually see a
really connective thread
through the three talks
that we've heard today.
And I would characterize
it as the reemergence
of ego or self-perception
in UX and UI.
So a lot of the threads
especially with work,
especially about what it
means to be user-friendly,
especially what it means to have
a consent where for a long time
there was a lot of
incentive alignment
between the technology, the
UX, and the business model,
which is essentially to
obfuscate all of this, right?
We all get the same UI
no matter who we are.
We all click on the things.
And for that, we
get things that are
really fast, that get
cheaper over time,
that I don't actually have
to give as much information
to use.
And what we're seeing
now is, it seems
like, the role of identity.
So if you go to
the doctors, a lot
of times the reason the
system's getting rejected
is because you're
trying to replace
part of what they consider
into their core identity.
For me to have representation
in the systems,
I have to give some
kind of feedback.
I really liked your comments
about one of the things
is when you have
a certain result
and I have a certain
result as a UX designer,
we need to design for us
to be able to compare them.
And what is that
experience like?
That's also moving a lot
of work that was obfuscated
and was taken care of by
the technology to people.
And I think of Cliff's comment
or thinking on user-friendly.
And user-friendly used
to mean get as much
of it out of the
way as possible.
And I think there's
this shift going
on where people are raising
their hand, perhaps, to say
I want to participate more.
And I actually
want more friction
because of what
I'll get in the end.
Sorry, I just wanted to
kind of connect those.
And if anyone wants to
talk about that topic,
I'd love to talk more about it.
SARAH GOLD: I think it's one of
the parts where user interface
design has kind of stayed the
same whilst the technology's
underneath these services
have radically changed.
And that's what we're facing.
Big questions are kind of
centered around that tension
point, really, that we've not
changed the way we design.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] don't
make me think entitled Make Me
Think a Lot, All the Time.
SARAH GOLD: Yeah, I think
that's where there's
a real tension there, which is
that I guarantee 99% of people
just won't have the time.
And so then you get a
new design challenge,
which is OK, how
do we start to look
at cooperative models, which
historically are places
that are really successful at
helping us do stuff together.
So I think looking to that
as well, which I don't think
has been part of the UX
language but should be.
SPEAKER 1: Thanks a lot.
SARAH GOLD: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Good.
Time for a break.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Thanks
to all our speakers.
And we'll start at 11:45 sharp.
Thank you.
Snacks are on this side.